[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لرائد الأعمال علي أمير لطيف ،
بدأ كل شيء بالتحدي
زراعة الفراولة العصيرية في
درجات حرارة تحت الصفر في فنلندا ،
ابنتي تحب
الفراولة لأكون صادقة معك ، فقد
كان الأمر يكلف إجابة عادية
قد تكمن في الزراعة العمودية
[موسيقى]
تأخذ المزارع العمودية بشكل أساسي مزرعة قائمة على
التربة وتضعها داخل
مبنى كبير عادةً ،
حيث تقوم بتكديس الصواني عالية إلى السقف
بدلاً من التربة ، وتستخدم وسطًا للزراعة
بدلاً من الشمس ، وتستخدم
المزارع العمودية مصابيح LED وتعتمد على التكنولوجيا
والابتكار للمضي قدمًا
للخلف  في عام 2015 ، وضع علي نموذجًا أوليًا
لمزرعة عمودية داخلية مستقلة تمامًا
2160 نباتًا في تسعة أمتار مربعة فقط
بمساعدة الذكاء الاصطناعي والتعلم الآلي
، تزدهر الفراولة ، كيف يكون المذاق
الجيد جدًا ،
يعتبر انعدام الأمن الغذائي خطرًا كبيرًا يواجه
العالم ولهذا السبب الابتكار في
الزراعة  سيكون مفتاحًا
لإطعام المزيد من الأفواه ،
وقد حضر علي للمعرض لإظهار كيف
يمكن لتقنيته معالجة هذه المشكلة.
الأنظمة اليوم تزرع
شيئًا واحدًا في كل مرة ، ولكن هنا يمكنك أن ترى
أن مزيجًا من كل جذر الشمندر
يوجد لفت في الأعلى هو ريحان قاع
التفاح الأخضر الحامض وهو عشب
لدينا ريحان الليمون هناك والفراولة
مع بيئتها التي يتم التحكم فيها بالذكاء الاصطناعي و
أسطوانات الغزل هنا ليست هناك
حاجة إلى تدخل بشري ، حيث يتعلم النظام
ويخلق نموذجًا ويخلق وصفة مقدار الأضواء
مقدار كمية ثاني أكسيد الكربون وكمية المغذيات وتلك
الوصفة ، ثم نشاركها في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، والهدف هو الحجم والسرعة
إنشاء بديل قابل للتطبيق
للأشكال التقليدية من  التربة الزراعية على
أساس 100 إنتاج تخسر 45 بسبب
آليات الطقس للطيور ووسائل النقل الأخرى
ولكن مع نظامنا لديك 100
إنتاج لا نستخدم أي مبيدات
أعشاب ، كلها عضوية
على الرغم من كل ذلك لا يزال هناك
طريق طويل لنقطعه
هناك
هناك الكثير من التحديات أمام المزارع العمودية ،
فهي تعمل على خفض تكلفة
إنشاء الأنظمة ، حيث لا
يزال علي متفائلًا  IC ويعتقد أنه
قادر على زراعة المحاصيل من حرارة دبي إلى
درجات الحرارة المتجمدة في فنلندا